was ist denn ihre Einschätzung zu dieser
Gemengelage die wir heute haben ist das
russische Propaganda wie ist das
einzuschätzen
also ich fand es interessant dass diese
Meldung dann doch heute in den
Morgenstunden doch so einen großen Raum
eingenommen hat auch in den deutschen
Medien auch in den ich sag mal seriösen
Medien nicht nur den sozialen Medien wo
das dann kolportiert worden ist
wenn man sich vor Augen führt dass die
Meldung aus dem russischen
Verteidigungsministerium gekommen ist
dann über die russische
Nachrichtenagentur weiter verbreitet
worden ist muss man die Informationen
doch stark im Zweifel ziehen zumal ist
ja doch ein klang schon sehr aufgebaut
was da drin war und das passt das ist
sozusagen der zweite informationsbit wo
man dann sehr vorsichtig sein muss es
passt irgendwie nicht zur gesamtgemenge
Lage dass das jetzt passiert sein soll
dann kam irgendwie noch die Meldung dass
dann der Oberpfalz aber der russischen
Truppen auch vor Ort gewesen wäre das
war was okay das jetzt ein bisschen zu
viele eigentlich ne und so kann man
eigentlich an dem Punkt aber nur sagen
auch im Verlauf des Tages heute für den
Interviewanfragen
nichts Genaues weiß man nicht und es
macht keinen Sinn da jetzt erstmal was
rein zu sagen wie gesagt ich war sehr
überrascht dass die deutschen Medien das
so aufgegriffen haben und das auch nicht
stark kontextualisiert haben gesagt
haben das ist nach russischen Angaben
wäre das so
ja ähm wo man so seine Informationen
herbezieht und wie man solche Quellen
auch verifiziert darüber sprechen wir
gleich noch im zweiten Teil der Sendung
lass uns noch mal lassen wir uns noch
mal kurz auf Belgorod schauen das ist
diese russische Stadt die relativ nah an
der Grenze zur Ukraine ist wo es in den
letzten Wochen Meldung gab dass
sogenannte antiputin Russen quasi
Anschläge oder Angriffe in Russland
selbst
ja vornehmen oder ausführen da gab es
jetzt auch wieder eine Meldung dass das
gestern wieder passiert sein soll wie
ist das denn zu bewerten was bedeutet
das jetzt gerade für den Krieg ja ich
glaube man kann immer versuchen solche
Informationen sind in drei Kategorien
einzuteilen das eine ist sozusagen das
was militärisch das bedeutsame daran ist
das was politisch daran bedeutsam ist
sowohl in Kiefer als auch in Moskau als
auch bei den westlichen Gesellschaften
und das dritte ist der reine
Informationswert oder das was sozusagen
auf der Information oder sag mal weil er
einfach Propaganda eben mit damit
fabriziert wird im Grunde genommen ja
wenn man das einstuft da muss man sagen
militärisch ist dadurch
viel gewonnen es versetzt aber Russland
möglicherweise in der Dilemma Situation
dass man sich überlegen muss müssen wir
jetzt Truppen dahin abkommandieren das
müssen keine Soldaten so das kann auch
Nationalgarde sein aber es ist erstmal
ein Dilemma und es wird durch die
Verquickung mit dem Informationsraum der
Propaganda wird es halt ein zusätzliches
Dilemma weil man diese Informationen
immer aus den eigenen sozialen Medien
den den Chat Kanälen den telegrams nicht
raushalten konnte und man steht
natürlich als der Kreml ein bisschen
peinlich da wenn man sein eigenes Land
und die Grenze nicht schützen kann das
ist sozusagen der die kleine Spitze die
da einfach nur mit drin liegt was das
politisch wiederum in Moskau bedeutet
ist immer sehr schwer eins zu sortieren
ob das jetzt sozusagen die
Tagesaktualität tatsächlich schon eine
große Relevanz für den Krieg hat ich
würde sagen in diesem Punkt erstmal noch
nicht aber die Tatsache dass es immer
wieder passiert kannst sagen einmal ist
keinmal aber wenn das sozusagen
dauermuster wird dann wird es
möglicherweise schwierig
bei ZDF heute live schon
ganz bei die Frage ist das jetzt die
ukrainische Frühjahrsoffensive gewesen
wann geht sie los sind jetzt vereinzelte
Aktionen die Kirche auch bestätigt schon
Teil dieser Offensive was würden Sie
denn sagen wie ist heute der aktuelle
Stand dazu ist sie jetzt losgegangen
ich würde auch dazu sagen das weiß ich
nicht die Frage ist warum ist wichtig
ist aber ich verstehe das sozusagen weil
es dieses Punkt Großoffensive
Gegenoffensive war früher als Offensive
weil er gesetzt worden ist dreht ist das
der dreh- und Angelpunkt der ganzen
Kommunikation wir würden es nicht wissen
und die Ukraine würde sich auch nicht
vorschreiben lassen wann sie eigentlich
die Offensive beginnt oder wie sie ganz
gerne sehen möchten ich glaube das ist
total wichtig dabei und es ist
sicherlich ein völlig falsches Bild wenn
man denkt da würde jetzt sozusagen
irgendjemand eine Trompete stoßen das
würde losgehen ne also das ist
sicherlich nicht das reale Bild dass man
von dieser Offensive haben wird wir
werden es irgendwann sehen und ich
glaube auch da ist es interessant dass
die sozialen Medien schon ein guter
Indikator teilweise sind weil sie eben
keine Informationen mehr wirklich
gehalten geheim halten können überall
gibt es Smartphones sie werden
irgendwann wenn diese Offensive
tatsächlich da ist dann werden sie sie
durchgelegte Videos sich alle diese
Sachen sehen kann aber natürlich auch
immer wiederum sein das ist fake ist und
da kommt eben da drauf an die
unterschiedlichen Witz und peace sein
Informationen zusammenzusetzen und sagen
okay kann es das jetzt sein stimmt das
jetzt und was bedeutet das dann
eigentlich jetzt für die Zukunft
ihr da draußen habt schon eine ganze
Menge Fragen gestellt ich bin hier
gerade schon mal im Job und da gibt es
auch einige die sich an sie richten hier
fragt osia auf Youtube wie ist es denn
zu bewerten dass ein russischer
Kommandeur der eigenen Führung
widerspricht das ist ja heute passiert
es gab eine Meldung des russischen
verteidigungsdienstes dass man diese
Erfolge eingeheimt hat und es gab aus
dem russischen Militär quasi schon
Entgegnungen nein das stimmt einfach
nicht jetzt fragt die Userin ist das
normal oder eher außergewöhnlich
das ist ganz schwer einzuschätzen das
sind ja so viele einzelne Informationen
wo jetzt sozusagen die eine die eine
Information das Verteidigungsministerium
hat was gesagt in Russland gegen diese
andere Information gesetzt wo man diese
sagen muss okay mag interessant sein
aber die Frage ist ja ist es tatsächlich
relevant natürlich kann man jetzt zum
Beispiel spekulieren dass es ähm wir
wissen dass die Moral offensichtlichen
russischen Streitkräfte nicht besonders
gut ist und das natürlich die Leute die
an der Front sind jeden Tag um ihr
eigenes Leben zu kämpfen haben weil sie
in den vergangenen Wochen und Monaten
gesehen haben dass sie planlos in den
Tod geschickt worden sind und das
deswegen sicherlich nicht nur eine
Frustration auf der intellektuellen
Ebene Blick auf das ist eine Lüge gibt
sondern dass man auch sagt hey die Lage
hier ist wirklich so blöd dass wir jeden
Tag sterben können
hier gibt's noch eine weitere Frage zum
Thema Belgorod hier schreibt jemand auf
YouTube wie hoch ist denn die Gefahr
dass die Lage durch die Angriffe in
Belgorod eskaliert auch in Richtung
nato-eu
das halte ich für gegen nullgehend ich
wüsste nicht wie daraus etwas werden
könnte
dass Moskau auf die Idee käme das gilt
für alle diese Fragen die in die
Richtung sind was das
eskalationsgefahr etc
Moskau hat ja jetzt schon große Probleme
in diesem Krieg irgendeine seiner Ziele
zu erreichen geschweige denn das
bisschen was man erreicht hat zu halten
dass man sich jetzt einen zweiten Front
aufmacht ist ja erstmal total
unwahrscheinlich also sich im Grunde
noch mehr Ärger ein handelt von daher
würde ich sagen warum sollten sie das
tun das ist ja auch nicht das russische
Interesse das russische Interesse sich
mit der NATO anzulegen das würde ich
auch absolut auf Null setzen dabei kann
man nicht gewinnen die Nato hat auch
gesagt wir wollen es auch nicht also da
gibt's sozusagen da gibt's wirklich eine
rote Linie von daher denke ich das ist
tatsächlich eher was was damit zu tun
hat dass die Ukraine versuchen für
Russland militärische kleine die lämmert
hat darzustellen die aber eben auch so
eine informationsdimension haben und
einfach sagen muss damit lassen wir euch
jedes Mal auch schlecht aussehen wenn
wieder so ein Trupp es schafft ins Land
reinzugehen und wieder zurückzukommen